This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到你的二十岁心理学，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的最大改变、重要时刻和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。
Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s, of your 20s. Hey, before we get into this episode, before we get started, I wanted to let you know that the full video version of this episode, of this podcast, is now available on Netflix worldwide. If you are somebody who prefers to watch rather than listen to your podcast or just likes having the podcast on in the background whilst you're cooking or cleaning or commuting, you can find us on Netflix. It is, candidly, a pretty new space for podcasts. So if you're a fan of the show and just want to help prove that podcasts are the real deal and that
欢迎回到本播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集，当然，我们要在这里剖析你的二十岁，也就是二十岁的心理学。嘿，在进入本集节目、在我们开始之前，我想告诉大家，本集播客的完整视频版本现在已在Netflix全球上线。如果你是一个比起听播客更喜欢看播客的人，或者只是喜欢在做饭、打扫卫生或通勤时把播客当作背景音，你可以在Netflix上找到我们。坦白说，这对播客来说是一个相当新的领域。所以，如果你是本节目的粉丝，并且只想帮忙证明播客是认真的，而且
people enjoy them and support them, genuinely the best way you can do that is to just go and watch an episode. That is my plea to you today. But what are we talking about in this episode? Today, we are talking about something that I think almost everyone has experienced at some point in their lives, which is the feeling of just being too much. You know, you're too loud. You're too emotional. You're too opinionated. Somebody's made you feel like you're too sensitive, you're too needy, too enthusiastic. I think at some point, most of us have had that sudden flash of self-consciousness where we just become acutely aware of ourselves, how we're behaving, and how other people are responding, perhaps in a less than favorable way. Maybe it's because you're laughing a little bit
人们喜欢并支持它们，说实话，你能做的最好的方式就是去看一集。这就是我今天对大家的请求。但我们在这一集里要聊些什么呢？今天，我们要聊一件我认为几乎每个人在生中的某个时刻都经历过的事情，那就是觉得自己“有点过头”了。你知道的，你太吵了。你太情绪化了。你太有主见了。有人让你觉得自己太敏感、太需要关注、太热情了。我想在某个时刻，我们大多数人都曾有过那种突然的自我意识闪现，开始敏锐地意识到自己、自己的行为，以及其他人可能以一种不太友好的方式做出的反应。也许是因为你笑得有点
too loudly and you realize everybody's kind of looking at you. Maybe you realize you've been talking for too long or, you know, you've shared something personal, you've immediately regretted it. Maybe you've expressed excitement, passion, love too soon or, you know, at too much of a level only to watch someone else's reaction and just think, oh, they're definitely going to tell people about this and it's not going to be nice. It's a genuinely and uniquely painful feeling and it can lead us to living very lonely lives because it goes deeper than just embarrassment, right? This feeling, it's bigger than that. What we're feeling is shame. When we feel too much, we feel shame. The sense that who we are naturally is somebody that won't be accepted and therefore
太大声，然后你意识到大家都在看着你。也许你意识到自己话说得太多了，或者，你知道的，你分享了一些私事，随即感到后悔。也许你太早或者在某种程度上过度地表达了兴奋、热情、爱意，结果看到别人的反应，心里只想：哦，他们绝对会把这事告诉别人，而且肯定不会说什么好话。这是一种真实而又独特的痛苦感觉，它会导致我们过着非常孤独的生活，因为它比单纯的尴尬更深，对吧？这种感觉远不止于此。我们感受到的是羞耻。当我们觉得自己过头时，我们会感到羞耻。那种认为自己天生就是不被接受的人的感觉，因此
if you want to find people to connect with, if you want to find people to be around, the only way to do that is to just shrink down a little bit. That is your only pathway to acceptance is to just not be who you are. I have such distinct memories and moments from my childhood, exactly like this, where I can literally see in hindsight, like the idea being implanted into my mind in real time that I was too much for people. And so I wanted to explore it today for others who may feel the same way because I think at its core, feelings of being too much are closely related to feelings of not fitting in, feelings that, you know, you never did belong that haven't found their resolution. And they won't find their resolution until you really dig into why it is that you're made to feel
如果你想找到能与之建立联系的人，如果你想找到陪伴在身边的人，唯一的办法就是稍微收敛一点。这是你获得接纳的唯一途径，那就是不要做你自己。我对童年有着如此清晰的记忆和时刻，完全就像这样，以至于我事后能真切地看到——那种认为自己对别人来说“太过了”的想法在实时植入我的脑海。所以我今天想探讨这个话题，希望能帮助那些可能有同样感受的人，因为我认为在其核心，觉得自己过头的感觉与那种格格不入的感觉密切相关，那种你（你知道的）从未真正融入、且一直没有得到解决的感觉。而且在真正弄清楚为什么自己会被弄得有这种感觉之前，这种感觉是不会得到解决的，
this way, the cost of feeling this way, and how it is that you can really just accept the bigger, louder, more out there parts of yourself. So without further ado, let's get into it. When you feel like you are too much, that feeling really stays confined to just like one area of life. It tends to follow you everywhere, even if it takes on different forms depending on the situation. For example, when we date, you know, we might consciously pull back from saying what we really want to say and admitting our true feelings, showing the other person that we're interested. or showing them too much of our personality. We may stop ourselves from doing those things prematurely so that they won't reject us.
这种感觉的代价是什么，以及你究竟该如何真正接受自己身上那些更大胆、更响亮、更张扬的部分。闲话少说，让我们开始吧。当你觉得自己过头时，这种感觉其实并不仅仅局限于生活中的某一个领域。它往往会一路跟随你，即使它在不同的情况下会呈现出不同的形式。例如，在约会时，你知道的，我们可能会有意识地克制自己，不去说出内心真正想说的话，不去承认真实的情感，不去向对方表现出我们的兴趣，或者向他们过多地展示我们的个性。我们可能会提前阻止自己做这些事，以免遭到拒绝。
At work, when we feel too much, we can feel like, you know, we're always the loud one. We're too demanding. Our standards are too high. We're too sensitive. And so, again, we don't ask for what we want. We stay silent when we really want to say things. We maybe lose out on opportunities because of that.
在工作中，当我们觉得自己过头时，我们会觉得，你知道的，自己总是那个吵闹的人。我们太苛求了。我们的标准太高了。我们太敏感了。所以，同样的，我们不会去争取我们想要的东西。当我们真想说点什么的时候，我们却保持沉默。我们也许会因此而错失机会。
Same in friendships. Same with your family. perhaps your family was the kind of family that was quite quiet and you embarrassed them. You know, the guiding thought we have is again and again and again, people would probably like me if I wasn't the way that I am. The core question we need to explore here is, to begin with, why does our society automatically tend to shame people who are too much into being less? Why is it not the other way around?
友情中也是如此。家庭中也是如此。也许你的家庭是个相当安静的家庭，而你让他们感到尴尬。你知道的，我们脑海中挥之不去的想法是：如果我不是现在这个样子，大家可能会更喜欢我。我们需要在这里探讨的核心问题是，首先，为什么我们的社会会自动倾向于羞耻化那些“过头”的人，让他们收敛？为什么不是反过来呢？
Why is it that we find loud, passionate? some might say brash individuals so polarizing, you know, inspirational at best, offensive at worst. It's interesting to me because society, you know, as much as I said, they don't tend to shame people who go the other direction. I do think they do. You know, people who are too quiet also are made to feel like they are less than. It's another example of like this impossible standard. You can't be too much, you can't be too little, you have to be just right. And very few people sit on that fine line. So there's a couple explanations as to why the too much person is is shamed. The first is that it challenges social norms. One of the deepest psychological reasons we
为什么我们会觉得那些吵亮、充满激情、甚至有人会说是鲁莽的个人如此具有两极分化性？往好了说是激励人心，往坏了说是具有攻击性。这让我觉得很有趣，因为社会，正如我所说的那样，虽然它们不倾向于羞耻化走向另一个极端的人。但我确实认为它们会的。那些过于安静的人也会被弄得觉得自己低人一等。这是另一个“不可能的标准”的例子。你不能太多，也不能太少，你必须恰到好处。而很少有人能坐在那条细线上。因此，关于为什么“过头”的人会被羞耻化，有几种解释。首先是它挑战了社会规范。我们在心理上将
label people as too much is because human beings are remarkably sensitive to social norms. Every culture, every workplace, every friendship group, family, community has this unwritten rulebook for how members should behave. What's appropriate to where? How loud someone should be. What gets said? What doesn't get said? Who's a top dog? Who's a follower? What's polite? What's not polite? It's always there. When someone exceeds those invisible boundaries, others think, you know, well, you're not playing by the rules. Why can't you just be like the rest of us? Why can't you just obey and continue this harmonious kind of feeling? This reaction is particularly the case for people who have a real rule-following, structured personality type. these people find the muchness particularly difficult to deal with, and they're often high in what
人们贴上“过头”标签的最深层原因之一，是因为人类对社会规范极其敏感。每一个文化、每一个职场、每一个朋友圈、每一个家庭、每一个社区都有一本不成文的规则手册，规定成员应该如何行事。什么场合穿什么衣服才合适。一个人说话声音应该有多大。什么该说。什么不该说。谁是老大。谁是追随者。什么是礼貌。什么是不礼貌。它一直都在。当某人越过了这些无形的界限时，其他人就会想，你知道的，好吧，你没有按规矩办事。为什么你就不能像我们其他人一样呢？为什么你就不能服从并维持这种和谐的感觉呢？这种反应对于那些有着真正循规蹈矩、结构化人格类型的人来说尤其明显，这些人发现这种“过量”尤其难以处理，而且他们通常在
we call conscientiousness, which is a big five personality trait that measures and reflects self-control, diligence, attention to detail, rule following, and it's also correlated with perfectionism, and at times authoritarianism and traditionalism. That final point I find really interesting. You know, there is a particular kind of individual who finds muchness offensive. one study I found from 2016 titled The Big Five in relationship with, I can't even remember, it's like the Big Five in relationship with social dominance orientation, looked at personality correlates in a sample of 400 people and, you know, who they voted for, what political parties they supported, and they found that people high in conscientiousness, there was a positive
我们所说的尽责性（conscientiousness）上得分很高，这是大五人格特质之一，用于衡量和反映自我控制、勤奋、对细节的关注、循规蹈矩，它也与完美主义相关，有时还与威权主义和传统主义相关。最后这一点我觉得非常有趣。你知道的，确实有一种特定的人会觉得“过量”具有攻击性。我找到的一项2016年的研究，题名为《大五人格与……的关系》，我甚至记不清了，大概是大五人格与社会支配倾向的关系，研究了400人样本中的人格相关性，你知道的，他们投了谁的票，他们支持哪个政党，结果发现，尽责性高的人，与保守、传统和
correlation with an increase in conservative, traditional, and at times authoritarian values. Some people just like rules and structure more. They want people to behave all in the same way. When you don't and they have that personality type, they look to correct that in you by making you feel too much and hoping the shame of that nudges you back in line. That's explanation number one. explanation number two, muchness, your muchness, reflects a self-acceptance and an authentic expression that other people feel is a threat. Psychology points to this idea that perhaps we dislike people who are confident because they make us feel that we are lacking. This has a name, it's called the self-evaluation threat. Essentially, a lot of our identity is based on how we
有时威权主义价值观的增长之间存在正相关。有些人就是更喜欢规则和结构。他们希望人们都以同样的方式行事。当你没有这样做而他们又拥有那种人格类型时，他们就会希望通过让你感到自己“过头”来纠正你，并希望这种羞耻感能促使你回到正轨。这是第一种解释。第二种解释是，“过量”——你的过量，反映了一种自我接纳和真实的表达，而其他人觉得这是一种威胁。心理学指出这样一种观点：也许我们不喜欢自信的人，因为他们让我们觉得我们有所欠缺。这有个名字，叫做自我评价威胁。本质上，我们的很多认同都基于我们如何
regard ourselves in relation to others. When someone displays traits or behaviors we secretly feel like we lack, we either feel worse about ourselves and our ego is injured, or we convince ourselves we actually don't like those traits. We don't want to be like that person. Therefore, we protect our ego by dismissing the value of this individual we're secretly a little bit jealous of. This really comes down to that one pesky social reaction that is hardwired into all of us, whether we like it or not, social comparison. Something we talk about a lot on the podcast is how comparison happens in two directions and what direction we choose to, I guess, direct it in, will influence how we feel about ourselves, also how we will feel about other people.
看待自己与他人的关系。当某人表现出我们暗地里觉得自己缺乏的特质或行为时，我们要么对自己感觉更糟糕，自尊心受到伤害，要么说服自己其实并不喜欢这些特质。我们不想成为那样的人。因此，我们通过贬低这个让我们暗地里有点嫉妒的个人的价值来保护我们的自尊。这实际上归结为那个刻在我们所有人骨子里、无论我们是否愿意都难以摆脱的恼人社会反应：社会比较。我们在播客中经常谈论的一个话题是，比较会在两个方向上发生，而我们选择朝哪个方向，我想，去引导它，将影响我们对自己的感觉，也会影响我们对其他人的感觉。
I think an example is probably needed here. The best one I can think of is like, imagine you hear that like your colleague has just made like a huge scientific discovery. They've like published something in a journal. They've won an award. They've received some accolade. It's a big deal. In response, you either can feel inspired by them, happy for them. You see their status rise and that's motivational for you.
我想这里大概需要一个例子。我能想到的最好的例子就是，想象一下你听说你的同事刚刚做出了一项重大的科学发现。他们在一本期刊上发表了文章。他们赢得了奖项。他们获得了一些荣誉。这是一件大事。作为回应，要么你会从他们身上受到启发，为他们感到高兴。你看到他们的地位上升，这会给你带来动力。
Or you feel crap about yourself. You feel stressed that you haven't achieved that yet. you find reasons to make their achievement feel smaller? The first reaction, the positive one, is upward social comparison. This person becomes what we call an expander for you, someone who has showed you what's possible and inspired you to reach it. The second reaction is downward social comparison. This person has become a threat.
要么你会觉得自己很糟糕。你会因为自己还没有取得那个成就而感到压力？你会找出各种理由来贬低他们的成就吗？第一种反应，即积极的反应，是向上社会这个人成了我们所说的你的“拓展者”，一个向你展示了可能性并激励你去实现它的人。第二种反应是向下社会比较。这个人成了一个威胁。
They've threatened you. They've made you feel worse about your. yourself, you feel in competition with them, and due to their success, their recent success, you are now losing that competition. You're not as good. This can start as what we call in psychology benign envy, which is relatively harmless. It quickly can transform into malicious envy if you're not careful, where, you know, you start doing things you don't see as a reflection of your character, you know, you criticize this person, you try and lessen their status, you accuse them or somebody's maybe accused you of being too much.
他们威胁到了你。他们让你对自……己感觉更糟，你觉得自己在与他们竞争，并且由于他们的成功，他们最近的成功，你现在正在输掉这场比赛。你没那么优秀。这在心理学中可能开始于我们所说的良性嫉妒，这相对无害。如果你不小心，它很快就会转化为恶性嫉妒，你知道的，你开始做一些你认为不是你品格反映的事情，你知道的，你批评这个人，你试图贬低他们的地位，你指责他们或者可能有人指责你太过了。
This also explains why your own muchness feels like a threat to people who internally feel too little. Someone else's own comfort in themselves can remind people of their own unheeled insecurity. They call you too much, they say you're too loud, too aggressive, too excited because they've silenced themselves. So why can't you? They've had to do it. You should have to do it as well.
这也解释了为什么你自己的过头会让那些内心觉得“不够”的人感到威胁。别人对自己感到的自在，会让人想起他们自己尚未治愈的不安全感。他们说你太过了，他们说你太吵、太具攻击性、太兴奋，因为他们已经让自己沉默了。那为什么你不能呢？他们不得不这样做。你也必须这样做。
They've denied themselves authentic expression. They've been internally hurt by that fact. Well, now everybody else should have to make the same choice and should have to pay the same price. In Australia, we have a term for when people feel threatened by other success. It's called Tall Poppy Syndrome. And it's this idea that the tallest puppy or the tallest flower is the first one to get cut down. The people who are doing the best, who are the most successful, the loudest, the most passionate, they are the ones others need to eliminate first if they want to feel better about their own
他们剥夺了自己的真实表达。他们为此在内心受到了伤害。好吧，现在其他所有人都必须做出同样的选择，并且必须付出相同的代价。在澳大利亚，我们有一个词用来形容当人们受到他人成功威胁时的现象。它被称为“高罂粟花综合症”。这个想法是，最高的那株罂粟花或最高的那朵花总是最先被砍掉的。那些做得最好、最成功、声音最大、最富有激情的人，是其他人为了让自己感觉好一点而需要最先消灭的人。
deficits or lackings. A great way to do that. Say that somebody is just too much. Shame them into being smaller. Paint them as going against social harmony in the name of humility. Like, you're doing this to make sure social order is maintained. Not really. The reason we do this is because of pride and because we can't bear to see somebody be better than us. An interesting psychological follow-up question is when does this feeling begin, right? We kind of know how it's implanted in us, but when does our muchness first start to feel like something that we need to internally correct or change to belong? There is this turning point around the ages of like six or eight, and then again, I think in our early teenage years when we often have our first experience,
对……他们的缺陷或欠缺。一个很好的方法。说某人实在是太过了。用羞耻感让他们变得渺小。把他们描绘成以谦逊的名义违背社会和谐。就像，你这样做是为了确保社会秩序得以维护。并非如此。我们这样做的原因是因为骄傲，因为我们无法忍受看到别人比我们优秀。一个有趣的心理学后续问题是，这种感觉是什么时候开始的，对吧？我们有点知道它是如何植入我们体内的，但是我们的过头是什么时候开始第一次感觉像是一种我们需要在内部纠正或改变才能融入的的东西呢？在六到八岁左右的转折点，然后再次，我认为在我们刚进入十几岁的时候，我们经常会有第一次经历，
of realizing that maybe people don't like us and realizing perhaps I don't fit in. People don't like me for who I am. This can happen with our families. It also happens with teachers, with friends, even random strangers. But I think the first place it really does begin is with our families and with our parents, especially when it comes to our bids for connection and our bids for emotional comfort. A big way children show that they want closeness and that they want. emotional support from their parents is through crying and through being loud and through trying
意识到也许人们不喜欢我们，意识到也许我无法融入。人们不喜欢我本来的样子。这可能会发生在我们的家庭中。它也发生在老师、朋友甚至陌生人身上。但我认为它真正开始的第一个地方是我们的家庭和父母，特别是在我们寻求连接和寻求情感安慰的时候。孩子们表现出他们想要亲密和想要的很大一部分方式。来自父母的情感支持是通过哭泣、通过大喊大叫以及通过尝试来获得的。
to get their attention. If an adult's response to your crying or your bids was to tell you to shut up or to stop crying or to get over it, if they became frustrated when you wanted attention, when they dismissed your upsets, something kind of clicks in you. You know, when I am loud, when I express what I need, I am made to feel bad. Therefore, part of me that needs is, that naturally needs and naturally wants must be inherently shameful and incorrect. We have to remember, you know, a big way that we learn what is socially and personally appropriate as children is by closely watching, monitoring, and responding to adults' reactions to our behavior. And so when we see people constantly be like, you are too much, we start to feel that.
引起他们的注意。如果成年人对你的哭泣或要求的反应是叫你闭嘴，或者别哭了，或者振作起来，如果当你想要引起注意时他们变得沮丧，当他们对你的心烦意乱不屑一顾时，你内心某种东西就会“咔哒”一声。你知道的，当我声音很大时，当我表达我需要什么时，我会觉得自己很糟糕。因此，我身上那个有需求的部分，那个自然需要和自然想要的部分必定本质上是应感到羞耻和不正确的。我们必须记住，你知道的，孩子们了解什么是社交和个人得体的一个重要方法是通过密切观察、监测和对成年人对其行为反应做出回应。所以当我们看到人们不断地说“你太过了”时，我们开始感受到这一点。
Does that mean we become emotionless? No. It just means we become very, repressed. That natural set point for our emotions, though, that remains. Like, we still feel all the feelings we would normally feel, but it's now constantly bubbling below the surface unable to be communicated and it becomes incredibly uncomfortable when we just can't express or be who we are. It's not just your tears or your cries that we're perhaps ignored as a child. Research shows that children who are overexidable, loud, boisterous, they often receive less preferential or favorable treatment from parents and teachers compared to children who are quiet and agreeable. The loud children are punished just for being themselves. Children pick up on
这是否意味着我们变得冷酷无情了呢？不。这只是意味着我们变得非常压抑。然而，我们情绪的自然设定点依然存在。就像，我们仍然会感受到所有正常情况下会感受到的所有情绪，但它现在不断在表面下沸腾，无法沟通，而当我们无法表达或做自己时，这种感觉会变得令人难以置信的不舒服。不仅仅是你的眼泪或哭声在小时候被忽视了。研究表明，与安静随和的孩子相比，那些过度兴奋、吵闹、喧闹的孩子往往从父母和老师那里得到的优先或青睐待遇更少。吵闹的孩子仅仅因为做自己而受到惩罚。孩子们注意到了
those reactions, especially since their sense of fairness is so heightened. And so when they see, you know, the nice, quiet girl gets a lot more praise than the loud child or the big brash child, we internalize that. We basically think if I want adults to like me, if I want people to like me, I better change because who I am now isn't good enough if it doesn't meet that standard. Personally, I had so many experiences like this when I was a kid because I was a happy and extroverted and enthusiastic child. Like I can acknowledge now that I really didn't do any harm, but I was just loud and I was just boisterous. The way some adults responded to my personality, is a feeling that I don't think you can forget.
这些反应，尤其是因为他们的公平感如此强烈。所以当他们看到，你知道的，那个乖巧安静的女孩比那个吵闹的孩子或那个粗鲁的大块头孩子得到了更多的赞扬时，我们将其内化了。我们基本上认为，如果我想让大人喜欢我，如果我想让别人喜欢我，我最好改变，因为我现在是谁如果达不到那个标准，那就不够好。就我个人而言，当我还是个孩子的时候，我有过很多这样的经历，因为我是一个快乐、外向和热情的孩子。就像我现在可以承认的那样，我真的没有做任何坏事，但我就是很吵闹，我就是很喧闹。一些成年人对我的这种个性的反应，是一种你认为永远不会忘记的感觉。
Like frustration at best, disgust, even a little bit of hatred at worst. And that sticks with you. That becomes how you feel about yourself, disgusted, annoyed, ashamed, I should be less. I remember one teacher I had, I can remember it so well. She would almost try and embarrass me for how loud I was. I think I was literally like seven or eight and she would get other children to copy how loud I was back to me. So I'd be like speaking loud and she'd be like, well, everybody speak at Gemma the way she was speaking. She would call me like loud Gemma and the other
往好了说是沮丧，厌恶，往坏了甚至还有一点点仇恨。而这会伴随着你。这成为了你对自己的感觉，感到恶心、烦恼、羞愧，我应该少一点。我记得我曾有过的一个老师，我记得太清楚了。她几乎会因为我声音有多大而试图让我感到尴尬。我想我当时真的只有七八岁，她会让其他孩子模仿我说话的声音有多大。所以我当时可能会大声说话，然后她就会说，好吧，大家用Gemma那种方式跟Gemma说话。她会叫我“吵闹的Gemma”，而班上的另一个
Gemma in class was nice Gemma. I was literally seven. She would ignore me when I like asked her questions or like I would try and I remember having these distinct memories of being like, I'm so excited by this art I made or trying to share something with her and she would just ignore me. And you know, I was the biggest and tallest and loudest girl in the class. I wasn't particularly delicate or neat. And I could see that even as a kid, like she had personal opinions of that. She didn't like that I was that child. I share that story, not for sympathy, not because I'm still hurt by it. I literally now get to talk and be loud for a living. It's obviously worked out pretty fine for me. But I just think it's a good example of what early childhood experiences and conditioning
Gemma是“乖巧的Gemma”。我当时真的才七岁。当我问她问题时她会忽视我，或者我会试着……我记得我有这些清晰的记忆，觉得自己对做的这幅画感到无比兴奋，或者试图和她分享点什么，而她却只是忽视我。而且你知道的，我是班上最大、最高、声音最大的女孩。我并不是特别娇小或整洁。我能看出，甚至作为一个孩子，她对此有个人看法。她不喜欢我是那个孩子。我分享这个故事，不是为了同情，也不是因为我至今仍为此感到受伤。我现在靠说话和声音大谋生。这对我来说显然结果挺好的。但我只是认为这是一个很好的例子，说明早期的童年经历和条件反射
does to our sense of self. Those early autobiographical memories of somebody not like a you for who you are doesn't just disappear. They are absorbed into our internal sense of self and shame and how we self-police our own behavior. The older we get. Eventually, we don't need someone. We don't need a teacher or a parent to tell us that we're being too much or to tell us to shut up anymore. We just do it ourselves. One 2016 paper from the Journal of Child Psychiatry talks about how children who were made to feel embarrassed by aspects of who they are, and it's not just whether they're allowed, but their looks or anything, they tend to develop more shame-proneness the older they get.
对我们的自我感做了什么。那些关于某人不因你本来的样子而喜欢你的早期自传式记忆并不会凭空消失。它们被吸收到我们的内部自我感和羞耻感中，以及我们如何自我监督自己的行为。我们越大。最终，我们不再需要某人。我们不再需要老师或父母来告诉我们我们太过了，或者叫我们闭嘴。我们自己就这么做了。2016年《儿童精神病学杂志》的一篇论文谈到了那些因为自身某些方面而感到尴尬的孩子，不仅是他们的声音大，还包括他们的外表或其他任何事情，他们长大后往往会发展出更多的羞耻倾向。
This was from a longitudinal study that started with 350 children in the fifth grade. It followed them until they turned 18, so a long time. More shame in childhood caused what these researchers labeled, as painful self-focus or painful focus on the self. And it was often accompanied by a need to shrink, to be smaller. As adults, these individuals also often resorted to a number of defensive strategies to escape the feeling that they were inadequate, everything from substances to overconfidence to self-sabotage.
这是一项纵向研究，从五年级的350名儿童开始。这项研究一直追踪到他们18岁，持续了很长时间。童年时期更多的羞耻感导致了这些研究人员所说的“痛苦的自我关注”或“对自我的痛苦关注”。并且通常伴随着一种萎缩、变得更小的需求。作为成年人，这些人也经常采用许多防御策略来逃避那种自己不够好的感觉，从物质依赖到过度自信再到自我破坏。
That was the consequence of this childhood reaction to their personality. So what are some of the other long-term psychological? effects. I really want to investigate these. We need to take a short break. When we return, we'll dive right into it. So what is the effect of constantly being told or implicitly made to feel like we're too much from childhood, even to adulthood? Could have been last week that you felt this way. First, if this began when you were a child, you were likely made to grow up a lot faster than your peers because you learned to emotionally and socially monitor your behavior early on. You also, you know, learned how to observe the reactions of others and the reactions they were having towards
这就是童年对他们个性这种反应的后果。那么，还有哪些长期的心理学影响呢？我真的很想深入研究这些。我们需要稍作休息。当我们回来时，我们将直接切入正题。那么，从小到大，不断被告知或被暗示觉得自己太过了，会有什么影响呢？你可能上周还觉得是这样。首先，如果这一切始于你的童年，你很可能被迫比同龄人更快地长大，因为你很早就学会了在情感和社会层面上监督自己的行为。你还，你知道的，学会了更早地观察他人的反应以及他们对你的反应。
you much earlier in life. This increases our level of social hypervigilance. That occupies a lot of mental space. It basically means that if you're a kid and you're trying to pay attention to whether the adults in your life like you, you have a lot less time and attention. to just be a kid and to just experiment and to just enjoy yourself and have fun. It also has the lovely added bonus of making us prematurely and rather intensely insecure. Now, some level of insecurity is natural with age. It's actually a good thing. It's what psychologists call the looking glass self,
这增加了我们的社会高度警惕水平。这占据了大量的心理空间。这基本上意味着，如果你还是个孩子，并且试图去关注你生活中的成年人是否喜欢你，你将会有少得多时间和注意力来做一个单纯的孩子，去尝试，去享受生活，去玩得开心。它还有一个可爱的附加好处，那就是让我们过早且相当强烈地感到不安全感。现在，某种程度的不安全感随着年龄的增长是自然的。这其实是一件好事。这就是心理学家所说的“镜中自我”，
the ability to imagine and understand how others may perceive us so that we can kind of meet important social norms. like we know not to hurt others, we know not to completely alienate ourselves, we know that's not good for our sense of belonging. But for someone who constantly feels like their personality is too big for their body, that people don't like them or expect them to be less, that looking glass self becomes a hyperfixation. That becomes something that we obsess over. I always think about this is like it almost creates a kind of like self-concept dysmorphia where similar to body dysmorphia we're like looking in this internal mirror and we're trying to figure out if like we're too
想象和理解他人如何看待我们的能力，这样我们就可以满足重要的社会规范。比如我们知道不伤害他人，我们知道不完全疏离自己，我们知道这对我们的归属感没有好处。但对于一个总是觉得自己个性对于自己的身体来说太大了、人们不喜欢他们或期望他们收敛的人来说，“镜中自我”就变成了一种过度关注。那成了我们痴迷的事情。我总觉得这几乎创造了一种类似“自我概念畸形恐惧症”的东西，类似于身体畸形恐惧症，我们在照一面内在的镜子，试图弄清楚我们是不是太大、太小还是刚刚好，以及别人如何看我们与我们如何看自己相比——我们能相信我们自己的自我感知吗？这就是内部发生的事情。觉得自己过头，也让我们与真实的自我脱节，从而使我们的身份分裂为真实自我和虚假自我。
big or we're too small or if we're just right and like how others see us versus how we see ourselves like can we trust our own self-perception that's what's happening internally feeling like we're too much also leaves us disconnected from our authentic self whereby our identity kind of splits there's this true self and there's this false self. Our false self begins to feel more and more like the real us because they're the version everybody sees and hopefully everybody likes. They're the version of us that is acceptable, the one that is smaller and nice and polite and the one we try and force ourselves into. But there will always be a disconnect that lingers and eats away at us. We will always know unconsciously, probably consciously, that there is a part of us that really wants to be
我们的虚假自我开始越来越像真实的我们，因为这是每个人都看到的版本，并且希望每个人都喜欢的版本。他们是我们中可以被接受的版本，那个更小、更好、更有礼貌的版本，也是我们试图强迫自己成为的版本。但总会有一种挥之不去、侵蚀着我们的脱节感。我们永远会在潜意识里（很可能是意识里）知道，我们身上有一个部分真的很想被表达出来，但我们做不到。我们的关系可能也会感觉没那么充实，因为，再次强调，人们喜欢的是虚假自我。人们投资的是虚假自我。而且他们对虚假自我投资越多，就越难真正展现真正的自己，并且不觉得自己会被拒绝。我前几天看到一句很棒的话。你知道的，如果你在躲藏，他们怎么找得到你？
express that we can't. Our relationships also might feel less fulfilling because, again, it's the false self that people like. And it's the false self that people are investing in. And it makes it harder and harder the more they invest in the false self to actually reveal who we are and not feel like we're going to be rejected. I saw this great quote the other day. You know, if you are hiding, how will they find you? And that is an excellent example of what feeling like, feeling too much feeling like you need to hide does to your ability to really find your people and to be accepted. Another thing that I don't see spoken about a lot, constantly suppressing our organic, naturally occurring emotions and feelings and reactions has a tangible and very real impact on your body,
这是一个极好的例子，说明觉得自己过头、觉得自己需要躲藏会对你真正找到同类并被接受的能力造成什么影响。另一件我没看到很多人讨论的事，是不断压抑我们的有机的、自然产生的情绪、感觉和反应，会对你的身体产生切实且非常真实的影响，特别是身体自我修复和照顾自己的能力。科学界有大量证据表明，自我压抑、自我意识的感觉与较差的身体功能之间存在巨大的科学联系。这是一个多方向的关系。2014年的一篇探讨我们情绪与免疫系统之间相互作用的论文回顾了一系列研究，发现表达或压抑四种关键情绪状态——愤怒、焦虑、喜悦和放松，都会调节细胞因子的产生。具体来说是体内的细胞因子蛋白。
specifically the body's ability to heal itself and to take care of itself. There is so much, there is a huge scientific link, I should say, between self-suppression feelings of self-consciousness and poorer physical functioning. It is a multi-directional relationship. One paper from 2014 exploring kind of the interplay between our emotions and our immune system reviewed a series of studies and found that the expression or suppression of four critical emotional states, anger, anxiety, joy and relaxation, all modulated the production of cytokine. specifically cytokine proteins in the body.
细胞因子蛋白，这些化学蛋白，是让我们的免疫细胞能够在细胞水平上进行交流并正常运作的物质。它们的产生正受到我们情绪状态的影响。当我们感到更高水平的焦虑、愤怒、沮丧和社交警觉时，当我们感到必须再进一步压抑这些事情所带来的紧张感时，这会减少产量，这意味着我们的免疫系统和免疫细胞在相互协作方面的表现会变差。另一方面，当我们觉得能够表达这些情绪时，当我们感到更少的紧张感，当我们感受到更积极、放松的情绪时，就会产生更多的细胞因子。这太重要了。我真的从未见过有人谈论这个。
Cytoquin proteins, these chemical proteins, they are what allow our immune cells to communicate and properly function on a cellular level. Their production is being influenced by our emotional state. When we feel greater levels of anxiety, anger, frustration, and social alertness, when we feel tension from having to go a step further and suppress those things, this reduces production, meaning our immune system and our immune cells are worse at working with each other. When we feel capable of expressing those emotions on the other side of things, when we feel less
当我们觉得自己太过了，当我们审查我们的情绪和感觉来创造一个我们认为更容易被别人接受的自我版本时，我们可能正在对我们的身体及其照顾自己的能力造成身体上的伤害。我们的身体会变得更难知道哪里出了问题以及无法治疗它。而这一切是为了什么？
tension, when we feel more positive, relaxed emotions, greater production occurs. This is so important. I literally never see people talk about this. When we feel that we have too much, when we censor our emotions and feelings to create aversion of ourselves that we think will be more palatable to others, we could potentially be causing physical harm to our body and its ability to take care of itself. Our body becomes worse at knowing what is wrong and being able to treat it. And for what?
简直是为了什么，为了别人的舒适，好让他们可能喜欢我们，好让他们可能帮助我们、接纳我们。当我们暗地里知道，这根本不是他们真正喜欢的我们，而是他们更喜欢的那个版本的我们时，我们正在为别人的舒适支付这笔债务。老实说，我不想说这是在自我破坏，但是，你知道的，我不想说这是在做糟糕的选择，但我们正在这样做，我们正在把我们自己和我们的身体置于一种不舒服、不健康，却又令人不安的状态中，仅仅是为了让别人不会因为我们而感到被冒犯。
Literally for what, the benefit of somebody else's comfort so that they may like us, they may help us, include us. When we secretly know, like it's not us they actually like, it's this version of us that they enjoy more. we are paying this debt for somebody else's comfort. We are genuinely, I don't want to say sabotaging, but, you know, I don't want to say making poor choices, but we are doing, we are putting ourselves and our bodies through an uncomfortable and an unhealthy, but an uncomfortable state just so that somebody else
这是一桩荒谬的交易。这是一笔荒谬的买卖。现在，我们到目前为止基本上略过不谈的讨论中，有一个极其庞大部分，在我们讨论社会如何对我们进行社会化改造以让我们变得更少时，起着巨大的、举足轻重的作用。那当然就是性别的影响，以及“太过了”这种侮辱更有可能针对女性而非男性的事实。这是一个有性别的侮辱。虽然我认为任何人都可以觉得他们太过了，100%是的，男性在很多情况下也确实会被弄得有这种感觉，但历史表明，女性因为占用空间而随后受到惩罚的可能性要大得多。而这种惩罚的一部分就是诸如此类的语言，旨在纠正女性不符合社会的举止和行为，以便她们循规蹈矩。
doesn't get insulted by us. And that is a ridiculous bargain. That is a ridiculous trade deal. Now, there is a huge part of this discussion that we've kind of swept over so far that has a like a massive gigantic role to play when we discuss how like society socially conditions us into being less. That is of course the effect of gender and the fact that the insult of too much is much more likely to be directed at women than at a man. This is a gendered insult. It is whilst I think anyone can feel like they're too much 100% and men are definitely
我觉得这对你们中的许多人来说并不是什么新闻。我觉得我们有点像把这当作女性主义入门来了解，但只是为了描述从A到B到C的整个过程，你知道的，从小开始，许多女孩就被社会化为随和、讨人喜欢、非常容易管理。这并不是自然而然发生的，而是因为我们受到了社会化改造，这给人一种印象，即女性和女孩天生就是这样的，再次强调，是因为她们在环境中被迫变成这样的，但因为它变成了一种全社会的现象，所以它看起来像是一种规范。因为我们把女孩培养成礼貌、成熟、乐于助人的，因为我们因此把这些特质与天生女性化混淆了，因为我们更多地奖励这些行为，甚至当女性长大后也是如此。这意味着，当有人不那样做时，当不符合女性行为的社会标准时，这些个人（可能是我们）就会被弄得感觉很糟糕，并且无法表现。他们不是融入社会的人。他们被迫感到羞耻。这也意味着我们开始自我监督并将这些女性气质的观念强加在自己身上。问题是这种行为模式，正如我所说的那样，不允许对“好女孩”标准有任何偏离。
made to feel this way in many circumstances, women have historically been far more likely to be subsequently punished for taking up space. And part of that punishment is language like this that is intended to correct a woman's unsocial mannerisms and behaviors so that they act in line. I feel like this isn't news to many of you. I feel like we kind of know this as like feminism one and one, but just to describe the whole process from like A to B to C, you know, from a young age, many girls are socialized to be agreeable, accommodating, very easy to manage. This doesn't just happen naturally, but because we are being conditioned, it gives the impression that women and girls are just like this, again, because they were environmentally
所以女性经常被置于一个不可能的境地。你要么可以做个好女孩，你可以有礼貌，你可以被人喜欢，但可能得不到你想要的东西。要么你可以声音大，你可以做你自己，你可以受到批评，但能够更加雄心勃勃地去追求你想要的东西。这被称为“可爱度悖论”或“可爱度惩罚”。它最早是由纽约大学和西北大学的研究人员提出的，他们研究了一种叫做“角色相容性”的东西。本质上，在某些行业中取得成功通常需要的东西，恰恰是根据人们对她应该如何行为的期望、根据他们认为女性行为轮廓应该是什么样的看法，而最容易招致人们对女性反感的东西。
made to be, but because it becomes a social wide thing, it seems like a norm. Because we raise girls to be polite, mature, helpful, because we therefore confuse that these traits as being inherently feminine because we reward these behaviors more, even as a woman gets older. What that means is that when somebody doesn't act that way, when the social standard of female behavior isn't met, those individuals, probably us, are made to feel bad and they cannot perform. They are not people who fit into society. They are made to feel shame. It also means that we start to self-police and self-impose these ideas of femininity on ourselves. The issue is this behavioral pattern, like I said, doesn't allow for any divergence from the
研究一再表明，自信、果断、野心等品质在男性身上通常被认为是非常积极的，但在女性身上则不那么积极。我认为它们实际上会激起大量的社会反弹，有时甚至会招来其他人的轻蔑。你知道的，一个为自己辩护的女性可能会被视为非常具有攻击性，一个自信的女性可能会被贴上非常傲慢的标签，一个充满激情的女性可能会显得非常专横、情绪化，一次又一次地我们看到这些类似刻板印象的东西出现。一个只是做自己的女性又一次被认为太过了。而这正是我们整集节目一直在审视的“太过了”这个标签不再是一种观察，而是变成了一种社会武器的地方。在这些情况下，它的功能就像一个警告信号。就像，不要声音再大了。不要自以为是。不要比人们预期的更显眼，因为我们不会再喜欢你了，你会受到惩罚。就像我说的，“太过了”是一种社会武器。它也有点像警告。它就像是，这是底线。不要越界。
good girl standard. So women are often placed in an impossible position. You can either be good and you can be polite and you can be liked and maybe not get what you want. Or you can be loud, you can be yourself, you can be criticized, but be able to be more ambitious and go after what you want. This is called the likeability. paradox or the likeability penalty. It was first labelled by researchers at NYU and Northwestern, and they were studying this thing called role congruity. Essentially, what is often required to get ahead in certain industries is the very thing
特别重要的是要认识到，这种警察式的管束并不仅仅来自男性。女性也会将这些期望强加给其他女性，在我看来，有时甚至更甚。我不知道这是否具有争议性，但从我所看到的来看，有时女性才是更多地纠正其他女性行为的人。对此有几个术语。内化厌女症可能是最著名的。水平敌意是另一个。这是社会心理学中的一个术语，用来描述一个边缘化群体的成员将批评、判断、攻击直接指向同一群体的其他成员，而不是挑战更广泛的系统，因为通过贬低你群体中类似的人——也就是其他女性，来赢得支配群体的青睐要容易得多。
that makes people dislike a woman more based on their expectations for how she should behave based on what they think a female behavioral profile should be. Research repeatedly shows this qualities like confidence. assertiveness, ambition are generally viewed very positively in men, not so positively in women. I think they can actually provoke a great deal of social backlash and a great deal of, like, sometimes even disdain from other people. You know, a woman who advocates for herself may be seen as very aggressive, a woman who is confident may be labeled as very arrogant, a woman who is passionate, may be very bossy,
不过，我认为最适用于这里的术语，是我们所说的“父权制交易”。这是土耳其学者丹妮丝·坎迪奥蒂（Denise Kandiyoti）在20世纪80年代首次提出的概念，她基本上指出，一些女性环顾四周，看到了她们反抗父权制所要付出的代价，然后决定还是选择明哲保身更容易。顺其自然会容易得多。成为父权制的一个小兵也会非常有益，希望父权制因为她们站在它这一边而对她们更好一点。而她们做到这一点的方法之一就是，批评其他出格的女性，
emotional, time and time again we see these like kind of stereotypes come up. A woman who is just being herself is once more too much. And this is where that very label of too much that we've been examining this whole episode becomes less of an observation and more of a social weapon. In these situations, it functions as like a warning signal. Like, don't be louder. Don't get any bigger for your boots. Don't be any more visible than people expect you to be because we won't like you anymore and you will be punished. Like again, too much is a social weapon. It's also a bit of a warning. It's like, this is the line. Don't cross it. What's particularly important to recognize is that this policing doesn't only come from men. Women can also reinforce
批评那些“太过了”的女性，来证明，你知道的，我是站在父权制这边的，我是站在你这边的，不要针对我，去针对她们。随着时间的推移，当这些经历不断重复时，会产生一种非常强大的内在叙事。与其认识到其他人的不适才是问题所在，与其认识到人们有权做自己、除了我们被社会化教育得不喜欢它之外，太过了或有意见或敏感或声音大本身并没有任何真正的问题。与其认识到这一点，许多女性、许多人开始相信：我是个问题。我表现出的这种行为是个问题，我需要做出相应的调整。
these expectations onto other women, perhaps even more so in my opinion at times. I don't know if that's controversial, but from what I've seen, sometimes women are the ones who correct other women's behavior more. And there's a few terms for this. Internalized misogyny is probably the most famous. Horizontal hostility is another one. This is a term from social psychology describing when members of a marginalized group direct criticism, judgment, aggression towards members of the same group rather than challenging like the broader system because it's easier to win favor with the dominant group by tearing down similar people in your group. so other women.
把这些期望强加在其他女性身上，在我看来有时甚至更加严重。我不知道这是否具有争议，但从我所看到的来看，有时女性反而是那些更多地纠正其他女性行为的人。对此有几个术语。内化厌女症可能是最有名的。横向敌意是另一个。这是社会心理学中的一个术语，描述边缘化群体的成员将批评、判断、攻击指向同一群体的成员，而不是挑战更广泛的体制，因为通过贬低你群体中的相似人来赢得占支配地位群体的青睐更容易，也就是其他女性。
The one I think applies best here, though, is what we call the patriarchal bargain. This was a concept first talked about in the 1980s by the Turkish academic Denise Kandioti, who essentially said some women look around, they see the cost they would bear of fighting back against the patriarchy, and they decide it would be easier to play it safe instead. it'd be much easier to just keep playing along. It would also be very beneficial to become a bit of a soldier for the patriarchy, hoping that the patriarchy is going to be nicer to them for being on their side. And one way they do it, criticizing other women who fall out of line,
不过，我认为最适用于这里的，是我们所说的“父权制交易”。这是土耳其学者杰尼斯·坎迪奥蒂在20世纪80年代首次提出概念，她基本上指出，一些女性环顾四周，看到了对抗父权制所需付出的代价，她们决定顺水推舟保平安反而更容易。继续顺应下去会容易得多。成为父权制的一名小兵也会非常有利，希望父权制因为她们站在这一边而对她们好一点。她们这样做的方式之一，就是批评那些越轨的其他女性，
criticizing women who are too much to prove that, you know, I'm on the patriarchy side, I'm on your side, don't go after me, go after them. over time these experiences, when repeated, can create a very powerful internal narrative. Instead of recognizing that other people's discomfort is the issue, that people are allowed to just be who they want to be, there's actually nothing inherently wrong with being too much or having opinions or being sensitive or loud other than that we've been socially conditioned to not like it. Instead of realizing that, many women, many people come to believe that I'm a problem. this behavior that I exhibit is a problem, I need to adjust accordingly.
批评那些表现得“太过分”的女性，以此来证明，你知道的，我站在父权制这边，我站在你们这边，别针对我，去针对她们。随着时间的推移，这些经历如果重复发生，会产生一种非常强大的内在叙事。与其认识到别人的不适才是问题所在，认识到人们完全可以做自己，除了我们被社会规训得不喜欢之外，表现得“太过分”、有观点、敏感或大声其实本身并没有什么错。与其意识到这一点，许多女性、许多人都开始相信我是个问题。我表现出来的这种行为是个问题，我需要做相应的调整。
I want to say, of course, men experience this as well. I think they just experience it in different ways. Many boys are taught that vulnerability, sensitivity, emotional openness are unacceptable. They are also labeled too much just in a different way. They're labeled too much when they express feelings that fall outside of traditional masculine norms. It's interesting how these all combine when, man is called too much. It's also often in comparison to a woman as well, you know, that you're being too much, like, are you just on your period? Like, you're so emotional.
我想说的是，当然，男性也会经历这种情况。我觉得他们只是以不同的方式经历罢了。许多男孩被教导，脆弱、敏感和情感上的坦诚是不可接受的。他们也常常受到过多的标签化，只是方式不同。当他们表达不符合传统男性规范的情感时，他们就被贴上了过多的标签。有趣的是，当一个男人被说“太情绪化”时，这些因素是如何结合在一起的。这也常常是和女性进行对比，你知道的，比如“你怎么这么多愁善感啊？”，“你是不是来大姨妈了？”就像你太情绪化了一样。
Like, why are you being, are you a woman? You know, that's all combined. Everybody suffers when there is this one idea of good, and that is somebody who is small, silent, and palatable. And the other version is not going to be accepted. The other way and place that we can see this is in celebrity culture, especially in the treatment of celebrities. I'm going to make this one final point, then I promise that I'll move on. But I'm sure a lot of you guys have noticed this or seen this cycle of female celebrities where we celebrate them, we celebrate them, we get them as big as we can get them, and then we tear them down the moment that they feel like it's okay to celebrate themselves as well. It's like, we're going to praise you until you believe us that you're good, and then we're going to make you feel foolish forever believing so. I have noticed this more and more the order I've gotten where every few years there will be a celebrity.
比如，“你为什么这样，你是个女人吗？”你知道，这些都是联系在一起的。当只有一种“好”的标准，即缩小自己、保持沉默、迎合他人时，每个人都在受苦。另一种选择是不会被接受的。我们能看到这一点的另一种方式和场合是在名人文化中，特别是在对待名人的方式上。我最后说这一点，然后我保证我会继续下一个话题。但我相信你们中的很多人都注意到了这一点，或者看到了女性名人身上的这种循环：我们赞美她们，我们赞美她们，我们把她们捧得越高越好，然而一旦她们觉得自我赞美也是可以的时候，我们就会立刻把她们拉下马。这就好像是，我们要赞美你，直到你相信我们觉得你很好，然后我们要让你觉得自己当初有这种想法是愚蠢的。随着我年龄的增长，我越来越注意到这一点，每隔几年就会出现一个名人。
darling who people just adore, especially if they're an underdog, especially if they're young. And they will get all these endorsements, all the invites, all the opportunities, all the praise. But as soon as they become even the slightest bit opinionated, the slightest bit, a little bit too loud, a little bit too something, they're cast aside and they are kind of depicted as deeply unlikable, difficult to work with, they're getting old now. This cycle happens like every couple of years. the actress and activist Jamila Jamil has spoken about this a lot. She talks about what it was like coming up and how, you know, special she was made to feel,
大家都非常喜爱的甜心，特别是如果她们是弱势群体，特别是如果她们还年轻。她们会得到所有的代言、所有的邀请、所有的机会、所有的赞美。但只要她们表现出一丁点的主见，哪怕只有一点点，或者稍微显得太高调、有点过于张扬，她们就会被抛弃，被描绘成极其令人讨厌、难以合作、而且现在开始变老的人。这种循环每隔几年就会发生一次。演员兼活动家贾米拉·贾米尔（Jamila Jamil）曾多次谈到这一点。她谈到了自己是如何成名并经历了这一切的，以及你知道的，她曾被捧得多么特别，
how welcome until she got to a point where she was overexposed. And then suddenly the press coverage like turned almost overnight. It blew minor things she said out of proportion. It painted her as somebody who was too loud, who was rocking the boat, who was a maniac, who was crazy. what she found interesting was like the media made money off of her when they liked her. And they also made money off of her when they convinced everybody to hate her for being too much. This isn't just her.
直到她达到了一个过度曝光的节点。然后突然之间，媒体的报道几乎在一夜之间就变了风向。它把她说的一些小事放大到了夸张的程度。它把她刻画成一个声音太大、喜欢挑事、是个狂热分子、是个疯子的人。她觉得有趣的是，媒体在她受欢迎时靠她赚钱。当他们说服每个人因为她“太情绪化”而讨厌她时，他们也靠她赚钱。这不仅发生在她一个人身上。
This is a pattern that we see time and time again. And I have to admit, it's a pattern that has influenced my opinion of female celebrities from time to time. For example, when I say these names, what do you think? See if this has influenced you. What do you think of these women? Megan Markle, Taylor Swift, Anne Hathaway, Jennifer Lawrence, Rachel Zegler, Billy Eilish. It feels like they have this glory moment and then they're just dropped. If you feel like you don't like one of them, can you explain why?
这是一个我们一次又一次看到的规律。我必须承认，这也是一个时不时影响我对女性名人看法的规律。例如，当我念出这些名字时，你们会想到什么？看看这是否影响了你。你对这些女性有什么看法？梅根·马克尔、泰勒·斯威夫特、安妮·海瑟薇、詹妮弗·劳伦斯、瑞秋·齐格勒、比莉·艾利什。感觉她们都有这样一个高光时刻，然后就被抛弃了。如果你觉得你不喜欢其中某个人，你能解释一下为什么吗？
Can you think of exactly why you don't like them? Where did that feeling come from? I'm not saying that all women should be immune from being criticized. I'm sure a lot of those celebrities have done. things that are genuinely probably not great. They shouldn't be immune just because they're women. But a woman seen as too much will often be cancelled much faster and harder than a man with literally serious crimes to his name. And a lot of that is tied up in how we shame muchness in women. And I think it needs to be examined from a psychological perspective, which is what we're
你能想清楚为什么你不喜欢她们吗？那种感觉是从哪里来的？我并不是说所有女性都应该免受批评。我确信很多名人做过的事情可能确实不那么好。她们不应该仅仅因为是女性就享有豁免权。但是，一个被认为“太情绪化”的女性，往往比一个名下有着真正严重罪行的男性更快、更狠地遭到封杀。这很大程度上与我们如何羞辱女性的“过度表现”有关。我认为这需要从心理学的角度来进行审视，而这正是我们正在
doing. Even Adele, one of the greatest singers of all time, do you remember when people were like running tabloids that she was like too loud. She was like too much. She's literally a soul singer. Like it is literally her job to have a loud voice. So if this fear of being too much exists at every layer or stage of society from childhood to adulthood, regular human to famous human, how do we unlearn it? That's what we're going to talk about. I'm so glad you asked. We're going to talk about so many ways that we can do this, including some maybe unconventional ones, after this short break. So we know that believing that we're too much
做的事情。甚至连阿黛尔——有史以来最伟大的歌手之一，你们还记得当时人们在小报上大肆宣扬她太高调了吗？说她太情绪化了。她可是个名副其实的灵歌歌手啊！用大嗓门唱歌本来就是她的工作。因此，如果这种害怕自己“表现过头”的恐惧存在于社会的每一个层面或阶段——从童年到成年，从普通人到名人，我们该如何消除它？这就是我们要讨论的内容。很高兴你问了这个问题。在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论很多可以做到这一点的方法，其中包括一些可能不太常规的方法。所以我们知道，相信自己“太情绪化”
is most certainly rooted in gender norms, in how we were treated as children, male or female, and importantly in other people's psychology as well and how they treat us based on their own insecurities. How do we counteract all of these things, all of these forces that have actually very little to do with us? well sometimes the only antidote to being too much is just being too much and just owning it. Like the first thing we have to realize is that not everybody is going to like you.
这无疑根植于性别规范中，根植于我们作为儿童（无论男女）时受到的对待，同样重要的是，这也根植于其他人的心理以及他们如何根据自己的不安全感来对待我们。我们如何对抗所有这些其实与我们自身关系不大的事情和力量呢？嗯，有时候对抗“太情绪化”唯一的解药就是继续做那个“太情绪化”的自己，并且欣然接受它。我们要意识到的第一件事就是，不可能所有人都喜欢你。
It is a fact of life that literally nobody is immune from. Nobody. If you think that there is someone that everyone in your life likes, I think you're mistaken, unless this person is like Dolly Parton or something. but I also think you'd be surprised about how much this person has had to self-police and suppress to be this universally liked figure. We suffer in one way or another. We suffer if people don't like us because we feel bad and we suffer if everybody does because we don't know who we are. We definitely have to compromise parts of ourselves to get to that point.
这是生活中的一个事实，没有人能幸免，真的是任何人。如果你认为你生活中的某个人是人人都喜欢的，我觉得你弄错了，除非这个人是多莉·帕顿之类的人物。但我也觉得你会对这个人为了成为这样一个全民皆喜的人物而进行了多少自我审查和压抑感到惊讶。不管怎样，我们都会痛苦。如果别人不喜欢我们，我们会感到难过，因为我们感觉不好；如果所有人都喜欢我们，我们也会痛苦，因为我们不知道自己是谁。为了达到那种状态，我们绝对必须妥协自己的一部分。
There is genuinely no winning. And I think that's a very important thing to remember. Not everybody is going to like you. It's just going to happen. The truth is that you're too much is always going to overwhelm people who have been asked to suppress those same things they see in you in themselves. Some people are going to be intimidated by your confidence. Others are going to find you irritating.
真的没有所谓的赢家。我认为这是非常重要的一点，必须牢记。不可能所有人都喜欢你。这种事就是会发生。事实是，你那“过多的情绪”总是会压倒那些曾被要求压抑你在他们身上看到的同样特质的人。有些人会被你的自信吓到。其他人会觉得你很烦人。
Someone might find you disappointing because you don't match their own. expectations. But if the opinion comes from them, it is their responsibility and it is their burden. It's not yours. They have ownership over that thought. If they thought it, it is their thought. The same way that you have ownership over your own thoughts about them, about people that you may judge. We all have those feelings sometimes. They belong to you, not the other person. Instead of thinking, you know, I can't believe they made me feel this way. I can't believe they think I'm this, think, I can't believe they were made to feel like they couldn't be who they wanted to be the way that I could. I can't believe they haven't had the opportunity to unlearn this.
有人可能会因为你没有达到他们的期望而觉得你很失望。但如果这种意见来自他们，那是他们的责任，也是他们的负担。不是你的。他们对那种想法拥有所有权。如果那是他们想的，那就是他们的想法。就像你对他们、对你可能会评判的人有自己的想法一样。我们有时都会有这种感觉。它们属于你，而不是另一个人。不要去想，你知道的，“我真不敢相信他们让我有这种感觉。我真不敢相信他们认为我是这样的人”，而是去想，“我真不敢相信他们被迫觉得自己不能像我一样成为自己想成为的人。我真不敢相信他们没有机会去摆脱这种刻板印象。”
I think pity is honestly one of the greatest antidotes to judgment. At least that's what I found. Secondly, I think it is imperative that you start to accept that there are unique benefits to being someone who feels very deeply expresses that, who is allowed, who is out there, if a consequence is some level of social judgment. You may actually belong to a very special group of people. We have a name for them. They know as highly sensitive persons, highly sensitive people make up only 15% of the population, according to some estimates. And as much as we need our practical, emotionless thinkers, or our creative thinkers, or whatever it is, we need our complex, sensitive, out loud thinkers as well. Highly sensitive people, if you think this may be you,
老实说，我认为同情是对抗判断力的最伟大解药之一。至少我是这么觉得的。其次，我认为至关重要的一点是，你开始接受作为一个情感极其丰富、敢于表达、真实展现自我并因此承担一定程度社会评价的人，有着独特的优势。你其实可能属于一个非常特殊的人群。我们给他们起了一个名字。据一些估计，他们被称为高度敏感者（HSP），高度敏感的人仅占总人口的15%。正如我们需要那些实用且不带感情色彩的思想家、或是富有创造力的思想家一样，我们也同样需要那些复杂、敏感、直言不讳的思想家。高度敏感的人，如果你认为这可能就是你，
they are individuals who feel and respond to the world very deeply, sometimes even painfully. A recent Guardian article talks about how highly sensitive people may be the missing personality type. You know, you just notice and feel other people's emotions as strongly as your own. You feel very moved by the world, by art, by small injustices. You make cry more, you may be more expressive and passionate about things. It may even influence how you respond to things like caffeine, things like noise, things like pain. It's thought that all of it's actually also genetic, hereditary, I should say. There was a 2023 study from, well, not from, but conducted in Saudi Arabia that kind of linked being this kind of individual
他们是对世界感受深刻、反应强烈的人，有时甚至会感到痛苦。卫报最近的一篇文章讨论了高度敏感的人如何可能是缺失的人格类型。你知道的，你注意到并感受到别人的情绪，其强烈程度就像感受你自己的情绪一样。你会被世界、艺术、微小的不公深深打动。你可能会哭得更多，你可能会对事物表现得更加情绪化和充满激情。它甚至可能会影响你对咖啡因、噪音、疼痛等事物的反应。人们认为这一切其实也是基因决定的，应该说是遗传的。2023年有一项研究，嗯，不是来自，而是在沙特阿拉伯进行的，它将这种类型的个体
to a kind of genetic component that's passed down through, you know, your parents and their parents that essentially influences how your brain processes emotion and responds to external stimuli. Also goes without saying can also be entirely not genetic. You know, if you're the only one in your family like this, don't go and think that you're, like, adopted. There's nothing wrong with you. Sometimes it's just our temperament. It's just who we are.
与通过你的父母以及他们的父母代代相传的某种基因成分联系起来，这种基因成分本质上影响了你的大脑如何处理情绪并对外部刺激做出反应。当然，这也不排除完全不是基因决定的可能。你知道的，如果你是家里唯一一个这样的人，别去胡思乱想觉得自己是被收养的。你没有任何问题。有时候这只是我们的气质。这就是我们本来的样子。
it is another unique part of how humanity has been formed and how we operate. And I think when you realize this about yourself, you realize you are this kind of person, you know, your life history starts to make a little bit more sense. You can realize that criticism you have received since you were a kid about being too much might come from people who just don't feel as deeply as you. They just literally can't access that depth. They don't ruminate as much as you. They don't understand what it feels like to not be able to.
这是人类形成和运作方式的另一个独特部分。我想，当你对自己有了这种认识，意识到自己就是这种类型的人时，你知道的，你的人生轨迹就会开始变得更有意义。你会意识到，你从小到大收到的关于自己“表现得太多”的批评，可能来自于那些情感不如你深刻的人。他们字面意思上就无法触及那种深度。他们不会像你那样反复咀嚼思考。他们不理解那种无法释怀的感觉，
to let things go because small things are so important to you. They just genuinely, it's like somebody who is colorblind trying to think about what it's like to see in color. You also need to appreciate that you are a needed and necessary part of society because your character, your personality has so many advantages that are needed in the world. Firstly, if the goal in life is to experience, you are already doing way more of that than the average person because you're feeling everything like 200% double the depth that the average person is. Secondly, you're better able to acknowledge and help people with their own struggles and kind of be that beacon. Highly sensitive people make excellent therapists, excellent teachers, artists, social workers, humanitarian workers, vets,
无法让事情就此过去，因为小事情对你来说都极其重要。他们真的——这就好像一个色盲试图去想象看到色彩是什么感觉一样。你还需要感激自己是社会中一个不可或缺的必要部分，因为你的性格和个性在世界上拥有许多急需的优势。首先，如果人生的目标是体验，那么你已经在做这件事了，而且比普通人做得多得多，因为你对一切事物的感受强度是普通人的200%，有着双倍的深度。其次，你更有能力识别并帮助他人应对他们自己的挣扎，并成为那样一座灯塔。高度敏感的人能成为出色的治疗师、优秀的教师、艺术家、社会工作者、人道主义工作者、兽医、
activists. Thirdly, you are more likely to be someone who is quite creative. You're more likely to have higher levels of emotional intelligence, greater levels of divergent thinking. Again, another huge benefit. Divergent thinking, by the way, if you haven't heard of this, is actually one of the greatest signs of pure intelligence that we know of. It's a distinct kind of thought process that allows us to have unique, creative, spontaneous thoughts. And it's a kind of thought process that allows people to connect ideas that often seem very unrelated together into one picture. You know, you see a problem and you can think of a dozen solutions that are out of the box, whereas most people could only think of one. You can maybe match small tunes to rhythms. You have
活动家。第三，你更有可能是一个相当有创造力的人。你更有可能拥有更高水平的情商、更高水平的发散性思维。再次强调，这是另一个巨大的优势。顺便说一句，如果你没听说过发散性思维，它是我们所知的纯粹智力的最大标志之一。这是一种独特的思维过程，能让我们产生独特、有创意、自发的想法。正是这种思维过程，让人们能够将那些看似毫无关联的想法联系成一个完整的画面。你知道的，你看到一个问题，就能想出十几种打破常规的解决方案，而大多数人只能想出一个。你能把小曲调和节奏搭配起来。你有
a business idea. Once a day, you know, you have all these different creative ways of thinking about the world that connect disparate ideas. That is a huge sign that you are quite a switched on person. And so your too much personality in that sense is an asset. It is an asset that has probably gone unappreciated by the people around you if you're feeling like it's something to be ashamed of. Another thing that's worth doing is just considering if you are generally too much or if there are just certain people in your life who make you feel that way, meaning that this feeling is situational and relational, not personal. I think it's often the case. What's fascinating is that some relationships do seem to expand us whilst others contract us, specifically ones that are
一个商业点子。你一天到晚都会冒出各种各样创造性的方式来思考这个世界，将不同的想法联系起来。这是一个巨大的信号，说明你是一个相当敏锐的人。从这个意义上说，你那种“过多的个性”是一种资产。如果你觉得这是件丢脸的事，那么这种资产可能一直没有得到你身边人的欣赏。另一件值得做的事情是，考虑一下你究竟是整体上表现得太多，还是你生命中仅仅存在某些特定的人，让你产生了这种感觉，这意味着这种感觉是情境性的和关系性的，而不是个人本质上的。我认为情况往往如此。迷人的是，有些关系似乎能扩展我们的胸怀，而另一些关系则会让我们畏缩，特别是那些
based around shame. The psychologist Carl Rogers spoke about the importance of this thing called unconditional positive regard, the feeling that you are accepted and valued without needing to constantly edit yourself. When we are around people who offer that acceptance, who accept our muchness, I should say, we tend to become more open, more spontaneous, more authentic, more confident. We talk more, we laugh more, we share our opinions without rehearsing them first, we just feel better. That's a very great kind of relationship. The opposite can also occur, though. Certain people make us hyper aware of ourselves in a restrictive way. And the longer you spend around these people, the worse you will feel about yourself and the worst you will feel about the core
围绕着羞耻感建立的关系。心理学家卡尔·罗杰斯（Carl Rogers）谈到了被称为“无条件积极关注”（unconditional positive regard）这一概念的重要性，即那种无需时刻自我修正就能被接受和珍视的感觉。当我们身处提供这种接纳、我应该说能接纳我们这种“过多的情绪”的人群中时，我们往往会变得更加开放、更加自发、更加真实、更加自信。我们说得更多，笑得更多，无需事先排练就能分享我们的观点，我们感觉好多了。这是一种非常棒的关系。然而，相反的情况也会发生。某些特定的人会让我们以一种限制性的方式对自我产生高度的觉察。你在这些人身边待的时间越长，你对自己的感觉就会越糟糕，你对你核心人格中
elements of your personality, you will believe that it is something to fix. In this way, as I said, your muchness is situational, it is relational, it is not personal, it is not a personal floor. This doesn't even need to be explicit. Like it doesn't need to be somebody telling you you're too much. It can be subtle. Research on nonverbal cues show that we often instinctively know when somebody is attempting to make us feel bad about ourselves through subtle changes in their tone, eye contact, body language, the positioning of their mouth. Even if we can't consciously put a finger on it, being around that constantly, knowing in this far away part of our minds, like, I don't think this person likes me, I don't think they like who I am, that has a
那些要素的看法也会越糟糕，你会相信那是什么需要修复的东西。通过这种方式，正如我所说，你的“过多的情绪”是情境性的，是关系性的，而不是个人的，它不是个人品格上的缺陷。这甚至不需要是明确表达出来的。就像它不需要是某人直接对你说你太多事了。它可能很微妙。对非语言线索的研究表明，我们常常凭直觉就能知道当某人试图通过其语调、眼神接触、肢体语言、嘴部姿势的微妙变化来让我们对自我感觉糟糕时。即使我们无法有意识地指出具体是哪里，但长期处于那种环境中，在我们内心的某个遥远角落里知道，比如，“我觉得这个人不喜欢我，我觉得他们不喜欢我是什么样的人”，这会产生
lasting effect. I need you to reconsider the nature of these relationships. Even if you are scared, the other side of this is going to be lonely, I promise you the space, the social space that you will open up, the acceptance that you will receive in the future from meeting people who love love you for who you are is going to be a million times more fulfilling than the temporary lack of loneliness that you get by avoiding these hard conversations or staying in these relationships. I think it's so difficult to separate ourselves from people who we've known for a while, who make us feel this way, but a family. And we know that a lot of people who feel too much report feeling very lonely and very isolated and misunderstood. But is that because you're just
持久的影响。我需要你重新审视这些关系的本质。即使你感到害怕，这种关系的另一面会让人感到孤独，但我向往你，你将开辟出的空间、社交空间，以及未来从那些因为你是谁而爱你的人那里获得的接纳，将比通过逃避这些艰难对话或留在此类关系中而获得的短暂摆脱孤独感，要丰富一百万倍。我认为，要我们将自己与那些认识了一段时间却让我们有这种感觉的人隔离开来是如此困难，但家庭就是这样。我们知道，许多感觉自己“表现太多”的人都报告说感到非常孤独、非常孤立且不被理解。但这究竟是因为你本来就
easy to misunderstand or is that because people just don't want to understand you or don't have the capacity? I think it's the latter and if they don't have the capacity, it means that there are people who do. The right people will find you when you make the space for them to step into your life. The right people will see your muchness and take it up like 10 levels. They will see your passion as an asset. They will love that you're allowed. They will want even more of you to love. see your muchness as more of you to love. You deserve people who can meet your level of depth, of emotional velocity, and complexity with their own level of those same things.
容易被误解，还是因为人们根本不想理解你，或者没有这种能力？我认为是后者，如果他们没有这种能力，那就意味着确实有这样的人具备这种能力。当你为对的人腾出空间让他们走进你的生活时，对的人就会找到你。对的人会看到你那“过多的情绪”，并将其提升十个级别。他们会把你的热情视为一种资产。他们会喜欢你的大声表达。他们会希望有更多属于你的部分去爱。他们会把你的“过多的情绪”视为更多值得爱你的地方。你值得拥有那些能够以同等水平的深度、情感威力和复杂性来与你匹配的人。
I think the early wounds of feeling like you're too much can make us think that that isn't out there, that we are like this isolated individual who needs to be ashamed and put away, but they are. So with that in mind, I want to wrap up this episode. I just hope that it's made you feel seen. I hope it's made you realize how common this kind of, childhood wound is and how many people feel like that they should be less than to find acceptance. I realize now, you know, I've been in the wrong environments for so many years in my
我认为，觉得自己“太情绪化”的早期创伤会让我们以为外面没有这样的人，以为我们就像个孤立的个体，需要感到羞耻并被藏起来，但其实是有的。带着这种想法，我想为这集节目做个结语。我只希望它能让你觉得被看见。我希望它能让你意识到这种童年创伤是多么普遍，以及有多少人觉得他们必须表现得卑微才能获得接纳。我现在意识到，你知道的，我生命中的很多年都身处错误的环境中。
life. I'm so glad that I finally found the right ones. Your muchness is not inherently bad. I just want to say that. You have just been socially conditioned to feel that way because of other people's expectations and at times their own self-consciousness. That can be counteracted. You can counteract that by recognizing three truths about who you are. One, your muchness stops being a problem when the people you surround yourself with are also at that same level of muchness. Two, your muchness stops being a problem when you realize that it makes up a wonderful part of who you are and it is a valuable addition to society. And, three, Three, your muchness stops being a problem when you direct it in ways that are creative,
我很高兴我终于找到了正确的环境。我想说的是，你的“过多的情绪”本质上并不是坏事。由于其他人的期望以及有时他们自身的自我意识，你在社会上被潜移默化地塑造成了这种感觉。这是可以被抵消的。你可以通过认清关于你是谁的三个真理来抵消这一点：第一，当你身边的人也处于那种同样浓烈的情感水平时，你的“过多的情绪”就不再是一个问题了。第二，当你意识到它构成了你作为一个美好部分的存在，并且是对社会的宝贵补充时，你的“过多的情绪”就不再是一个问题了。第三，
exciting, and helpful. And then you'll realize that all that shame you were made to carry has just been completely misdirected and has been completely not helpful. Embracing this part of you is going to just unlock a whole new side of life. So I hope, again, this episode has helped. I want to thank our researcher Lucy Davidson for her contributions. If you want to learn even more about this feeling and about this unique kind of childhood wound, you can read the full episode transcript on Substack.
当你以富有创意、令人兴奋且有帮助的方式引导它时，你的“过多的情绪”就不再是一个问题了。然后你会意识到，你被迫背负的所有羞耻感都被完全错误地引导了，而且完全没有帮助。拥抱你身上的这一部分将为你开启全新的人生。所以，我再次希望这集节目对你有所帮助。我要感谢我们的研究员露西·戴维森（Lucy Davidson）做出的贡献。如果你想更多地了解这种感觉以及这种独特的童年创伤，你可以在 Substack 上阅读完整的节目文稿。
I will leave a link down below. We will also have additional resources, including some of the papers that we cited in the description down below. As always, if you haven't yet, please watch an episode on Netflix. It would help us greatly. Truly, it really would. So I'm going to, again, leave a link down below. I feel like I say that 20 million. times every episode but you know where to find it until next time be safe be kind be gentle with
我会在下方留下一个链接。我们还将在下方的描述中提供额外的资源，包括我们引用的一些论文。和往常一样，如果你还没这样做的话，请在 Netflix 上观看一集节目。这会对我们有很大帮助。真的，确实如此。所以我会再次在下方留下链接。我觉得每集节目我都要说这个2000万次，但你知道在哪里可以找到它。下次见之前，保重，保持善良，对自己好一点，
yourself especially if you resonated with this episode we will talk very very soon this is an iHeart podcast guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
特别是如果你对这集节目感同身受的话。我们很快很快就会交谈。这是一个 iHeart 播客，真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。